[Music]
[Laughter]
what's up my babies it's episode 121 of
congratulations and welcome it's brought
to you by the cash because one fire said
I was good to talk and I wasn't good to
talk because the theme song wasn't over
yet did he ruin the beginning of the
show yes is it okay
yes will we get back on track yes did it
[__] with the vibe a little bit yeah but
I'm a professional comedian and a
professional talker so will it be okay
yes it will be fine
is he still one fire uh-huh absolutely
but my babies were here and we're doing
it and it is episode 121 and it is
[__] you know what I woke up today
and I was like I was like look maybe we
should push this podcast to Wednesday
because I wasn't feeling it I wasn't
feeling it I woke up today and I'm still
tired from doing all the early flights
even though I don't need to because my
routing was supposed to be easy enough
to where I wasn't doing the flights
early because the flights weren't too
long so I didn't have to get up too
early and my agent said it was gonna be
all good and it wasn't all good because
there were only connecting flights
unless I took the early flight which was
a straight shot so I ended up taking the
early flight anyway and therefore I am
[__] absolutely goddamn exhausted now
it's okay yeah I'm here
because I woke up and I went to
Starbucks with Lou Anna and I got some
coffee that tastes like a [__] open
cow's mouth and I drank it and I sat
there for a while and I collected my
thoughts and I feel and I feel good man
I feel fire I feel good so now we're
going and then we go and we start and
one fighter says I can start and I can't
start and it's pissing me off and it's
all good it's pissing me off is all good
okay but I was in Edmonton and I was in
Vancouver Island which is a
a [__] island off of Vancouver it's
called Victoria its Victoria BC and it's
a big-ass island and there's no bridge
to get there you got to take a prop
plane or you got to take a boat or a
ferry and we took a plane from Edmonton
to Victoria and it had those little
[__] me
you know what I mean those prop plant
those [__] just two engines were if
one blew out you're done one blows out
you're done you're done if a blade flies
off that thing II done sayonara that's
it dude so we did that I want to get it
was like one of those planes were like
that he was just the next step below the
plane was like the plane with the two
bubble domes on it and your [__] and
there's two seats and you're just either
in in the front seat or the back seat
and you have to wear a [__] scarf and
goggles dude whatever happened to those
planes where you could [__] where
they didn't even have a dome and you
just had to wear goggles dude like like
like it's like just like you're not
going 4,000 miles an hour Wow
aviator you know motorcycle style
[__] the aviator hat you know imagine
being on a plane where you had to wear a
hat for safety hey dude one of those
[__] engine goes one of those engines
go sayonara you're twirling towards the
ground
oh man that's that's anyway so we did it
and it's fine and it was bumpy is bumpy
as [__] cuz the planes so small but it
was all good and so so I did that I was
in Edmonton I'm and I'm live on my app
right now if you want to get the crystal
Lea app you can see the Peppa sewed
before anybody the beginning of the
episode before anybody and you know it
is what it is remember those planes that
would they put where they will put the
[__] shark's mouth at the end dude
how [__] stupid is that where you try
to paint your [__] plane that looks
like an animal dude how confusing is
that also you're not even painting your
plane like an animal that flies you're
painting your plane like a [__]
sharks face
hey man sharks go I don't know if you
know this but sharks gone the ocean dude
I saw the end of Aquaman
on the plane by the way and all I gotta
say about that is hey dude he's
underwater and he's talking to like the
[__] big-ass lizard thing and and
it's like you cannot have the scepter
and he was like I'm getting that scepter
and they were like you can't have this
scepter and then the [__] big-ass
thing was trying to swing its tail
around and kill [__] Aquaman and his
hair looked all goddamn beautiful
because he was underwater and then and
then and then he got the scepter and
then one you know how about people will
be like oh don't ruin Aquaman like you
thought maybe it would end a different
way dude
he got to set hey at the end of Aquaman
he gets the scepter in every one of
those goddamn movies man the bad guy has
something then the good guys like I
gotta get it and the bad guys like nope
I got it and the good guys like watch me
and then the good guy gets it anyway
he'd they were talking underwater and it
didn't even sound like he was like oh
I'm gonna get that scepter it was like
echoey underwater so and then she's like
and then the [__] girl who made all
that [__] up about Johnny Depp being
abusive what's her name
Amber Heard was like hey you're the King
now and ah dude how do you direct movies
like that for real I want to be in a
movie like that so goddamn bad it's
unreal just to where I'm just like the
guy [__] no matter how dope no matter
how I train my body no matter how hard I
trained [__] martial arts and doing
the [__] they moan no matter how much of
my faculties I had with me no matter
what I would still if I was one of those
parts I'd still look like the guy like
that old vine of the guy that's like
almost killed you dude how [__] is it
to wear long sleeve shirts for real I
have a long sleeve shirt on right now
and it's so [__] too like you gotta
wear short sleeves early
if you were a long-sleeve shirt it's
pretty [__] unless as a caller this is
just what I think I don't know whatever
dude I don't even know why the [__] you
listen to this podcast for real it's a
goddamn train wreck
but we love you for it my babies and I
was in Canada and let me just tell you
something about Canadians man they're
the night and here's how I figured this
out so I was in Edmonton which is by the
way it might as well be America it's the
it's the most American Canadian city
I've been all around Canada and the most
American Canadian city is not North
Battleford do you know why because it's
a goddamn Canadian I went there and
didn't North Battleford I told the story
about North Battleford and the guy asked
me to go ice fishing
acet Canadian but Edmonton it might as
well be [__] America for some reason
it's so American and I went to a bar
there to eat afterwards it was the only
place open and we ate food and everyone
was like annoying the [__] out of me you
know coming up and drunk people were
like Oh Chris Lu what the [__] are you
doing here and it's like what do you
think I'm doing in Edmonton and they say
a show and I go yup they say can I get a
pic and I say sure yeah let's do it
quick and then the guys like okay oh hey
dude come over here use it like whoa
whoa but everybody but but I realized
everyone was like you know quote-unquote
annoying the [__] out of me but like it
was fine and I realized like everyone
was they just really
I left the the place with like a really
nice feeling I mean dude I must have
talked to [__] 25 people there that
came up to me and and I left and I was
like man in America if this happened I
would be leaving in such a bad mood
because people would be such [__]
[__] about it but Canadians are just
nice as [__] dude they really give you a
good feeling it's such a nice place
everywhere you go it's such a great then
I went to Victoria and there's islands
like this island of [__] like
beautiful people and and like and also
got
there's so many Asians in Vancouver and
like that area what's the deal with that
I guess I don't know what to populate
why the let's look up to the Asian
population in in Vancouver um but but it
was just like nice-ish [__] man and like
I thought it sucks how cold it is but
like everyone just III found myself in
two days in Canada just having such a
[__] positive outlook on life and
like a positive thing the crowds were
great I would if I didn't have to live
in LA to [__] make it or to stay
relevant I'd live in Canada no doubt if
they'd have me I probably [__] up their
whole vibe but uh yeah nah love it love
Canada Canada congratulations men
it's just great your your a great place
so
also also yeah watched Aquaman and it
was [__] insane on that little ass TV
on the plane it's so funny to complain
about little less TV on the plane is
like you're 30,000 feet in the air and
you [__] watching TV and you're still
like this TVs too little but I took I
took WestJet which is there like I'm
like there's no Wi-Fi this is how I this
is how the plane looked on WestJet this
is how I asked this there's that you can
tell how the plane looked with the way I
asked this to the stewardess hey there's
no Wi-Fi on this plane huh and she was
like no not that this is how they always
sang it dude this drives me nuts this
how they always say if you say if you if
you if you say if there's no Wi-Fi on
the plane and you say is there Wi-Fi on
this plane and there isn't Wi-Fi on the
plane this is how they [__] say it
they go like this no on this not on this
plane there isn't oh just say no dude
just say no it's like you're trying to
[__] be like what look the company
isn't that bad they have other planes
that it is but this plane
hey it's 2019 dude planes have been
around for what over a hundred you know
how when did it first plane invented if
Planes been around 450 if something's
been around for 50 years already there
better be goddamn Wi-Fi on it do you
know I'm talking about
there's toasters with Wi-Fi on it for
real you can get a toaster and hook it
up to your [__] Wi-Fi no doubt if
there's that then planes have Wi-Fi on
it I'm a big proponent I know there's
that whole thing which I was gonna get
to when I said there should be Wi-Fi on
all the planes and how the TVs are too
small and [__] there's a whole louis c.k
bit where he's like you know you stop
complaining because where you're in the
air listening to [__] or watching TV
or whatever the [__] dude I don't agree
with that if you have some [__] and it's
invented make it work or don't invent it
dude I don't agree with that bit the
bits funny I get it but like no complain
dude if the [__] doesn't work complain
when I go on stage I do my job I [__]
rip my babies I try hard I make it work
if it didn't work you complain I guess
sometimes I bomb maybe I'm wrong there I
love though when there's a a [__] oh
by the way did you see the I mean
Schwarzenegger got [__] drunk let me
tell you about this [__] man
Schwarzenegger was in where was he South
Africa chillin in a gym taking videos of
like our girl doing jump rope like a
sweet guy trying to [__] be like yeah
look at the way she jump rope though how
Ollie you know and this guy flew across
like literally flew into frame in every
in every shot that they angle that they
have because of course people are
videoing it because his artists or
second people videoing and whenever he's
anywhere in every angle that got
uploaded online the guy who did the jump
kick is flying into frame so this guy is
an unreal flying jump kicker
like flying into frame always with two
feet to like it looks like for his
friends through him like swung him
around and was like here we go get your
feet out you're gonna [__] knock the
[__] out the Terminator and he flew into
frame everytime and kicked the middle of
Arnold Schwarzenegger back okay if
anybody kicked the middle of art of
anyone's back that you know they go down
but honest war snigger didn't move dude
he he literally goes what the [__] and
turns around like one of those bad old
cartoons that's like gets punched and it
is like is there a fly in here you know
and he [__] and he turned around like
he probably only went a hell a little
bit you know when he got kicked he
probably would just one hell and then
turned around he's like who this dad how
and then the guy the the bald bodyguard
guy just [__] kind of like a little
bit choke the person out but I was like
I mean the guy didn't put up a fight
after that do you think I put up a fight
like he was like no I know I just draw I
tried to dropkick one of the most famous
guys in the Rose all guys all good it's
all good it's all good and then [__]
they of course escorted him out but dude
how about I know that this is just like
the [__] obvious stance to take but
how about how Schwarzenegger is the
Terminator how about how Schwarzenegger
took that [__] double footed kick
like what bro if you spit on me I'd fall
down if you spit on me I'd go whoa and
fall down and [__] all over and I was so
scared to come
a flying jump kick from off-screen do
you know how [__] far the kick came
from is off-screen that's how far if
some [__] comes from off-screen that
[__] is so far
if you ever reading a script and you're
like off-screen a car rolls that you're
like okay that's a that's a [__]
that's from far away what the [__] was
he trying to do and then on the first
[__] roll I'm fine I just honestly
thought someone bumped into me I said
the man eze sorry I just thought that
someone was trying to run a boat bump
into me how dude I know this is so dumb
to talk about but for real
imagine having sex with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and when he had an orgasm
you were like well that's the [__]
thing he does like you know he goes oh
that would be so weird to it to actually
be a girl and go on dates with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and then like he [__]
beds you and then you're making love and
he's like oh you'd be like that's
actually so that will be a [__] mind
[__] you'd be like oh my god dude he
actually does that that's crazy
that's so crazy people have had
with arnold schwarzenegger you know like
there's a there's some people that are
just like so lucky that they had sex
with our on the Schwarzenegger if you
had sex or associate you're lucky as
[__]
like I would never have sexual orifice
here but like if somebody was like yo
you want to have sex one resource [__]
I'd be like I mean I don't know I I
don't think so but it wouldn't be like
no like now dude I get it but now but
yeah he took that kick like a champ bro
he took that he took that kick like
somebody like a you know he took that
kick like a lead actor the lead um god I
love these [__] uh I love these uh
what do you call it the like finales and
[__] like they bring out the [__]
like anytime a show ends like it's weird
how like so after it it's like the
during this show of whatever you talk of
whatever you're talking about star wars
game of Thrones anything it's like
during it you don't realize how dorky it
is and then afterwards you really
realize how dark it is
so like I'm on season five of Game of
Thrones I don't I don't you know i don't
i don't i'm not caught up but I know the
finale was obviously this past weekend
and people are upset with the way it at
first of all it's so hard to sustain a
[__] show for eight seasons okay um I
know that because every show I've been
on has been cancelled after three or two
okay but there's Pete
Kishen there's a petition to redo the
last [__] season of Game of Thrones
like look that up sophie turner slams
fan petition to remake Game of Thrones
Season eight up like do you understand
the level of glasses pushing up
dorkiness you are do you understand the
level of look just you are the level of
excuse me I was actually in line level
of it you know it just makes me laugh
dorky you are is is off-the-charts dude
it's that flying jump kick off the
charts from you're off you're off screen
coming in in the dork mobile to be like
dude we got to start the petition I mean
you're the guy outside of the Lakers
[__] Staples Center protesting about
the Lakers management hey you're the
first to go
they're not gonna remake [__] season
eight of Game of Thrones they're not
gonna make another goddamn episode maybe
in ten years they might make a prequel
or some [__] but dude they're not gonna
make a [__] a million people signed
it a million of you are the first to go
a million of you just exposed yourself
you're the first to go line up you're on
the front line when someone says when
someone says oh dude they got a remake
the season 8 of [__] Game of Thrones
and I'm gonna sign the petition you say
you you say get out there that's what
you say to them and they say what and
you
say well you're the you're on the front
line dude you're not gonna be making
decisions people tell you what to do do
die son did you sign the piss oh you one
of the million people here you go get
out there here's a gun here's a gun dead
out there
protect our minds protect our
decision-making minds you cucks dude are
you [__] [__] me imagine taking a
[__] pen or signing in logging in wow
this matters enough to me remake season
8 of Game of Thrones bro no they did it
you watched it
see ya it didn't end the way you liked
it and guess what make a show make a
show where it ends the way you want it
to end make that show as a matter of
fact get all the [__] people together
remake Game of Thrones you got a million
of you remake Game of Thrones Season
eight so I'm telling you petition
[__] there's a million of you
that signed at that sign - that you guys
signed it that how about this you get
together and you remake season eight of
Game of Thrones you do that
I'll watch that you do that as a matter
of fact I guaranteed how much will
people watch that sophie Turner is
putting a viral petition requesting a G
ot season 8 remake on blast it's
disrespectful to the crew and the
writers and the filmmakers who have
worked tirelessly over 10 years you know
[__] you [__] dorks here you go
get out there attaboy yo you're about to
get shot in the head for our minds look
at this
look at this and people from different
languages just being dorks look someone
just commented please under it like
that's gonna help somebody just
commented under the remake the petition
things please hey men you're literally
the first to go
you're literally the guy who gets the
first gun what happened here here get
out there soldier why am I the first one
ouu oh please under the petition you
thought it you thought you should sign
in you gave him your email ping ping and
you sign in under the petition and
remake Game of Thrones Season 8 you
wrote PL EA se thing here get out there
okay I don't really understand but you
didn't even give him a helmet no I know
he's just a [__] he's a god did you
know why it's cuz he's a [__] goddamn
idiot and he's the biggest [__]
glasses pushing up dork of all he's from
the thing is dude he was the mayor of
dorks Ville that's why that's that's
what happened he was the [__] mayor
of of tucks landing that's why I mean
dude come on man I don't like what they
did to dinner it she was the hero for
90% of the series and you know it's like
this makes me laugh how [__] I just
don't like you know it's like it's like
scroll up should we get another one here
you know it's like even the writers into
the final seasons it was supposed to be
the fact there are almost 1.5 million
people signing with King
that's the guy looking for his arm and
[__] Saving Private Ryan that's that
guy that's what he's saying
there earlier seasons were magical
because the writers were had you know
all the published books and worked for
reference this is actually poorly
written rushed with abandon storyline
arcs and that's look that's what the
guys saying looking for his arm I'm the
[__] opening scenes than that when
you're storming the beach in Normandy
when you throw him in the beads in
Normandy and the in the [__] in the
Saving Private Ryan movie did how how
dorky was that when people thought it
was funny to say saving right hey have
you seen saving Ryan's privates there's
a porno name of that for sure okay look
I got to do some ads and then I'm gonna
tell you a story about my [__]
uncle's mom Dave dot-com if you're like
me you're not always paying attention to
your bank account balance you know why
no dents usually right and the moment
you see you're going to be overdrawn is
too late because let's face it sometimes
for people out there dents end up
spending thirty seven dollars on a cup
of coffee thanks to the bank fees no I
mean let's face it that's kind of
idiotic and it sucks
introducing the Dave app putting an end
to overdressed fees overdraft fees for
good so if you got dents out there
sometimes because of overdraft fees Dave
is the number one budgeting app in
America because it saves you from
overdraft fee's tells you about upcoming
bills and can advance you $75 from your
next paycheck with no credit check and
no interest see so get the Dave app for
just one dollar per month that's 12
dollars a year which is way less than an
overdraft fee and you will never have to
pay one again ever do $12 a year
no dents let's get the Dave app the Dave
app will help you budget for upcoming
expenses text you if you're spending too
much and if you need cash fast it's like
a friend that's like Yale bro chill Mark
Cuban is an investor in Dave because he
got crushed by overdraft fees in his
twenties and wants you to never pay an
overdraft fee again speaking away
so did I and it was annoying as hell go
to Dave comm / Congrats it really helps
the show if you let them know you heard
them here then download Dave and never
pay another overdraft fee again it's
immediate savings so go now
Dave com / Congrats spelled it just like
it sounds da ve Dave com / Congrats open
fit getting fit and staying healthy
always sounds easier said than done
right open fit is bringing you something
new that makes it even easier to never
miss a sweat session lose the commute to
the gym and let workouts come to you you
know what I go to the gym sometimes and
it's like two hours because it's now
we're getting there and back and then
also doing the workout is an hour and
this this eliminates that but everyone's
bodies are different and open fit gets
that which is why it's personalized to
your needs with custom tailored original
content amazing trainers and classes
open fit classes are led by some of the
most effective and engaging trainers in
the world sculpt your body with Andrea
Rogers founder of the worldwide
sensation extend bar or get in crazy
good shape with Hunter McIntyre named by
Sports Illustrated as one of the top 50
fittest athletes so they know how to get
you results real quick super simple
forget all the complexity and stress
around getting fit and just press play
and workout on your on your schedule
it's awesome access anywhere anytime
results you can see lose up to 15 pounds
in just the first 30 days flatten your
abs shape shave your body you know how
it goes open fit has changed the way I
workout and with my code Congrats you
can join me on a fitness journey
personalized just for you again use my
code Congrats and start using open fit
for your journey to a healthier life
right now during the open fit 30-day
challenge my listeners get a special
extended 30-day free trial membership to
open fit where you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days when you text congrats
to 30 30 30 you will get full access to
open fit all the workouts and nutrition
information totally free again just text
congrats to 30 30 30 those are the
numbers okay yeah but
don't be a desert and don't sign how
about this don't sign petitions for TV
shows okay they were trying to [__]
sign petition dude did the other thing
about the Robert Pattinson playing
Batman like he's gonna maybe probably
get the Batman part and then there are
people like no no no no way I can't see
him as Batman well guess who can the
people who were [__] creating Batman
also what do these peep these people who
think Robert Pattinson shouldn't play
Batman I'm all for it by the way go
ahead go ahead
he looks like he could be Batman you're
only saying that he can't play Batman
straight up you're only saying that
because of Twilight okay
and you're saying that because that
people just wanted to hate that show
because it was a [__] it was for
teenage girls and like all that's so
[__] oh it's so corny it's so stupid
it's not actually good but you saying no
way I won't stand for Robert Pattinson
playing Batman and making a petition and
bitching about it online makes you a
teenage girl so what the [__] he are
what you hate you don't like Robert
Pattinson playing Batman because he was
on Twilight because you didn't like that
[__] because it was for teenage girls so
you go online and you start a petition
or sign a petition about how Robert
Pattinson would be a bad Batman and how
he shouldn't play it because you're a
teenage girl
that's what happened you're no better
than that [__] you doin Jude tell one
you [__] forty five-year-old bellied
out [__] type typist just [__]
complaining and bitching online about
how robber pad [__] that why can't he be
Batman cuz he was in Twilight so what
we're those movies corny show what you
know it's [__] corny a guy dressing
up as a [__]
that it's all corny dude let them
[__] pick people thought Michael
Keaton back in that when wouldn't be a
good Batman
imagine if the internet existed they'd
be up in arms
you're not gonna dude you don't matter
you don't matter dude if you're making a
petition about then the Sonic the
Hedgehog [__] it's like dude you don't
that that was crazy when people are like
oh Sonic the Hedgehog oh man no like why
all this hate on the way Sonic the
Hedgehog look in the movie who cares and
then the [__] producers oh I think
they actually went back and we're like
alright well we're gonna dude you
[__] buckle and ask [__]
[__] that uh I don't know man maybe I
got the one minute I'm the one the
problem if I was a producer sonic
hedgehog and then somebody was like dude
no way that's not how it should look
guess what happened
you just solidified the way at goddamn
look stand up for some especially for
some dumb [__] like sound like the
Hedgehog man come on dude dude just just
think about complaining just think for a
second about complaining about something
called Sonic the Hedgehog like it's a
blue hedgehog with sneakers on okay and
you're 40
also I swear to God I thought it looked
cool when I don't was like oh wait
people are hating on this I was like I
love this artists fix his live-action
Sonic the Hedgehog and then like it got
like a million retweets or some [__] and
it's just like the only thing he did is
make his [__] dick area less and he
made him shorter a little bit and it got
[__] 89 thousand likes oh no sorry
325 thousand likes if you like that
you're a dork straight up first to go
here you go get out there so crazy did
one of the [__] UM stories I was
gonna tell you when I said before the
the break was uh about my uncle
so he had this house um Utah and he
wasn't there and his mom was there and
she was there with her friends and this
was in the tooth early 2000s and she
called my uncle from Utah and he was in
LA I think and she was like hey so my
friends and I sat down to finally start
watching The Sopranos is it usually this
graphic and my uncle said wow it's a
pretty pretty graphic show yeah people
get killed and stuff and she was like
now I'm talking about the sex and he was
like uh I mean sometimes their sex
scenes in it huh yeah and he said yeah
but it's really like that's all it is
he was like what are you talking about
this it's not just sex like just she's
like oh my god she says I'm watching the
support OHS she ordered a porn called
the Sapporo's instead
dude first of all celled woman you know
thought she was watching The Sopranos
turned it on people were but [__]
each other and then she realized after
calling someone while people wall people
were on screen but [__] that she was
watching the Sapporo's instead look at
the Sapporo's thing look at the end then
they made the support nose to up and of
course they made some porn was four and
five dude how about how many sequels
they make four pornos they don't give a
[__] that's how he that's how much you
know storylines don't matter you know
that they just keep making sequels like
they can't even make [__] eight
seasons of Game of Thrones without
people [__] bitching and then sit and
then they'll just be like it'll be like
this suppor knows 95 I mean dude look at
how gross how dumb are guys that they'll
just see it and they'll be like oh look
at that one up there on the upper right
dude support knows to look at the guy
unreal dude James dig digi dujour jaws
of course danger George Oh James to
Georgia hey dude
James did Georgia you know for [__]
sake James did Georgia Dame Jane how do
you say that James did Georgia hi I'm
James - Georgia I go [__] yourself
picket pick a different on the Sapporo's
three and the guy on it dude the only
Moret on you could be by the way then
actually acting in The Sopranos is
taking your dick out you know and that's
what these guys do the most Italian you
could be is in a [__] silk
button-down opened up thing with a hairy
chest and a chain and a cigar with
sunglasses on and your pants are down in
your
Dick's out and you say hey you guys get
over here and you're talking to [__]
like permed out white chicks you want me
to suck your [__] hey yous guys get over
here Tony wants me to suck his [__]
again alright I'll do it
look after the lasagna on the stove
I gotta suck Tony's [__] suppor knows
you know it's like dude suppor knows
what likes and not clever do these sex
the sex [__] things would be like
don't even try they'll be like yeah but
you know we got to make the sex vengers
right yeah we got to make the [__]
vengers it's between the sex Avengers
and the [__] vengers we got iron [__] man
and captain dick America they're like
okay I'm sure and then we got [__]
who's the who's the [__] Charlotte
who's the [__] why was forget her
named the one is marrying Colin Jost
Jost Scarlett Johansson her character
we're just gonna call her [__] [__]
girl we don't even know her name in the
thing Black Widow will call her [__]
[__] it's all good and then [__] iron
[__] man will call Hulk Hulk but it'll
be about his [__] you know his [__]
Hulk his [__] will get big and green
right he'll say he'll I just have a big
[__] [__] and it'll get big and green
and then some girl and then [__] I'll be
like I'm not your big green [__] and
then she'll be into it on [__] and
she'll [__] suck his big green [__]
right then we'll have [__] nebula
will call her [__] beulah then Thanos
will call them [__] big balls Thanos
or something just big balls will call
them big balls and I'll have big purple
[__] balls and we'll put the Infinity
stones on his ball
this is the [__] for real and they
don't even try and then they're done
with the meaning and then and then we
got spider-man will call him [__] [__]
guzzler come he'll be gay call him [__]
ghazal man go back then we'll go to
[__] Nick Fury you guessed it you
guess what we'll call him of course I
mean do we even need to say it
let's all say it on the count of three
three two one dick fury great we all
said it of course there we go
we'll put an eye patch over his [__]
left balls a star [__] Doctor Strange
we'll call him [__] doctor come
doctor jizz let's call him doctor jizz
and then when he jizz is it'll open up a
portal and then [__] [__] girl we'll
get into it go two more to the left
who else we got Rocket Raccoon we got
Loki Bucky Barnes will call him [__]
come one two three come on come too and
come three black panther we'll call them
black [__] panther groot will call him
root I mean dude what is I didn't
realize the Asian guy's name is Wong
Wong
s-sir racist that's his name in the
[__] Avengers Wong okay why does it
say Wong Wong Oh Benedict Wong is
playing long oh wow okay well they were
like war me we gotta get him right also
dude I love when the Asian guys are
named [__] like Ben Benedict you ain't
foolin when I was a kid I went to school
with so many Asian kids and their names
would be like the [__] old the old
American names that people don't use
anymore like George and Hank it will be
like Hank suck and we'd be like hey man
you know at least pick [__] Charlie
or [__] Dave you know
they would be like the girls will be
Mary and grace and the guys would be
George and [__] Hank oh yeah hey Hank
Wang so funny all right
uncommon apothecary today's episode is
brought to you by on uncommon apothecary
CBD is from the hemp plant but unlike
its sister Mary Jane CBD contains less
than 0.3 THC won't get you high but stop
you from feeling low
all products are third-party lab tested
to ensure quality several double-blind
studies have shown CBD to reduce anxiety
and I'm all for it also been shown to
alleviate depression as well as pain and
inflammation and that's a good thing man
a lot people out there with some real
problems with depression and anxiety and
this stuff is has been shown to help so
they it's also the best of all of it is
that it's it's legal without
prescription in all of 50 states they
also have pet formulas so your best
friend can and you can take it together
I mean dog or hell I don't know maybe if
you've got a snake just give it to the
snake I don't even know make sure to
sign up for monthly deliveries of
uncommon apothecary so you are never out
when you need it and also save an
additional 10% off head over to you a
dash CBD calm today and use the code
congrats at checkout to receive 15% off
for congratulations listeners and see
why thousands are switching from
prescriptions to a more natural
alternative for every item purchased
uncommon apothecary will donate $1 to
local homeless shelters and that's very
sweet again that's you a - CBD calm and
use the code congrats for 15% off at
checkout thinking of I'm thinking about
trying
I haven't yet but one fire loves it for
anxiety and Ivan likes it too
Ivan get rid of so it you know it really
works
ten thousand look a real problem exist
it's way too hard to find the perfect
pair of workout shorts I know some of
them are too big some of them chafe you
know shave you know chafe whatever is
but it does and it sucks right gives you
a rash some of them are too short too
long whatever are not comfortable or
sweaty you don't find out that it's
comfortable until you sweat right and
then you find out they're uncomfortable
but ten thousand makes the highest
quality best fitting and most
comfortable shorts you've worn I wore
them working out and they were good
through and through
I sweating them I don't sweat in them
either way they're comfy three premium
training shorts built for all the ways
you train one built for versatility in
every workout that's the one I like one
built for durability in the toughest
workouts and one built to be super
lightweight and fadeaway why trained
they create the best fitting most
comfortable and highest performing gear
available CrossFit HIIT running spin
yoga lifting you name it and even your
weekend adventure go hiking in these
they're really great they're really
lightweight and they're awesome and
10,000 lets you choose your own length
and liner option so you get the perfect
training shorts that's why they're great
because you know usually the shorts just
come in like two sizes and you get Spaak
check out the 1,500 five-star reviews
from real customers voted by men's
health as the best training shorts of
the year
so visit 10,000 dot CC / congrats for
20% off your first order and they sent
me a bunch of stuff and it's really
great and I think that you'll like it so
go for it my babies
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app please download the cash app I
asked nicely so thank you let me do a
bunch of these
just because there were
and also where's that going it's backing
up to my house it's backing up to my
house I need to get a [__] dump truck
dude just so it can [__] raise up and
fall out all disrespectful on my [__]
driveway for all my bags to just [__]
like this [__] if you're watching the
video just like this just bags dropping
cuz of the ad just [__] disrespect -
all falling out and I'll leave some
there is what it is done my babies
suppor knows but yeah so I I don't like
this how it I can't [__] how come I
can't do the thing with the were the
[__] things over on my thing whatever
it did one working what oh wow but also
how do i okay now I don't man okay I'm
pissed
um okay now I can't get it back we're
like how do I get it back where is
everything
oh I got a [__] drag it oh wow on
fire made me make all this stuff go away
and now I can't get it back no it
doesn't dude now it gets to this look at
this look at all those icons oh he
doesn't know he [__] me royally dude
command tab oh wow dude I put the caps
lock on like a [__] it won't come up
though it's stuck in the [__] corner
dude whatever it doesn't matter you know
what it doesn't matter we're doing it
we're doing it no I mean it's fine do it
[__] it
here we don't need this [__] but what I
do need to tell you is I [__] went to
online and I was thinking about my old
college roommate dude one time this how
[__] petty I am man I had a college
roommate that was I think he was I think
he was I don't know what his nationality
was I think he was Indian but we got
along until we didn't get along because
we were just [__] sleeping next to
each other on [__] twin beds in a
[__] small college dorm you know and
one time man we probably annoyed the
[__] out of each other I definitely know
this [__] out of him I know I did this
is not like I'm this is not one of the
stories Rawls like he was an [__] he
was not an [__]
I was probably an [__] as well just
annoying wise we didn't like [__]
fight or anything but I remember one
time I left so hard because I was
annoying him and I was singing that song
let me lick you up and down until you
say stop and he goes like this
stop and I [__] howled because he did
what they said in the song and I was not
even [__] expecting it but anyway
there was one time where he also used to
talk about now that I think about it how
[__] much this is well before 9/11 he
would talk about how much he liked Osama
bin Laden which is actually now that I
think about it pretty [__] crazy
you'd be like Osama bin Laden is better
than Bush he would say that okay okay
well now remember that song I'm gonna
lick you up and down until you say stop
why am I not connected to the Internet
here here we go it's called it's called
freaked me from silk remember that song
a lot of you young uns probably don't
know that song silk this is how it goes
freak me baby oh yeah so sexual what is
what debugging also second sensual you
know R&B isn't usually this consensual
let me lick you up and down until you
say stop so not sexy are you all good
with this just let me know
oh yeah you know we have a safe word
that's if I pull your hair too hard you
say [__] banana or some [__]
[Music]
but yeah so I I did that and he said
stop
and I [__] cried laughing and then he
would annoy the [__] out of me though
and then when I left I left before him
and out of the school year and I and I
you know there wasn't there were cell
phones but we also you would still have
the [__] landline and I took I took
the the receiver of the phone and I know
and I went outside and I threw it away
so he couldn't find the receiver that
was my last laugh
that's how petty I am what a [__] move
that I did that but I did do that but I
looked him up and this was a crazy thing
about the Internet man I looked him up
and like he's got a family now and he I
think he's in India and he's got like a
wife and a baby he only had two pictures
on the Instagram and they were both from
2014 but it was nice to see him again
everybody gets a little bit fatter huh
as they get older and I'm not saying
that he did I'm just you know what I
mean though right wink you know I'm
saying and I'm not trying to be like I'm
not necessarily saying that he got
fatter but all isms saying is I saw his
picture and it was 14 years later and
all I'm saying is
everybody gets a little bit fat or don't
they and I'm not trying to say that
that's what happened to him but you do
the math right
remember these songs dude goddamn these
songs murder this one how much all these
guys bald now just [__] is there
anything more pleasing to the human ear
for real than that harmony right there I
mean it's just so awesome one time I was
hanging out with my buddy not the
smartest guy in the world but he said
did you know that um you can did you
know that one of the most beautiful one
of the most beautiful sounds they say in
science is when um brothers harmonize
and I was like Oh for [__] sake and he
meant it and I was like who are my
friends
this song rips
[Music]
dude oh my god what am i a [__] radio
DJ you guys we got Color Me badd coming
up here we go all right this guy seems
so gay what girl would [__] wanna
[__] a guy who sings this kind of [__]
you know I mean this I had to [__] it so
funny but but girls would be like oh my
god they would throw themselves that
[__] Color Me badd what girl would
want to [__] a guy that sings that kind
of [__] that's so hilarious dude waiting
on that so just let me hold you close to
me
hey shut [__] I mean come on dude the
[__] first comment I love this kind
of [__]
Lorenzo buyers rights I love the 90s
with a passion exclamation points let's
see what people say about him somebody
else rights under that 70s made Philly
Motown I mean okay
that's so funny that people really leave
maybe I'm the people really leave
comments like it they matter dude look
at this every time I hear this song I
want to park at the beach and make love
to my girlfriend who is now my lovely
wife so glad I was in this era love the
90s and 80s on a youtube comment hey guy
get a blog and eight replies dude what
are these people saying to this guy
awesome
so very very sweet makes me remember
that there are some good men left in the
world
ah because of a comment this guy could
be [__] jerking off the kid porn and
then oh and then somebody comments love
her and then someone puts that's
beautiful you put a ring on it and then
someone comments to that 1980s and 90s
were incredible
some missing the point somebody else
writes you need to be cloned dude
somebody else writes those were the days
bro like he was there watching them [__]
outside of the car just like with the
[__] song playing just some creep
some guys are making love to his
girlfriend and he was outside like this
from a [__] dune
from behind a dune like this near a
trash can with just a long shirt on and
his tics get part
he's jerkin and then he puts the
binoculars down in Turks but then he's
like [__] but I can't see when a jerk
because I can't use them binoculars do
they put the binoculars back up and jerk
upon hand and use binoculars use another
hand and then you [__] bust a nut
when on the tick-tock II you don't stop
dude
I tick tockia you don't stop then this
is the best this is the best somebody
comments wow this is the best somebody
comes this song is still relevant till
this day what do you mean dude they're
talking about a [__] you know it's
always relevant [__] oh this is this
guy I like what the hell were we
listening to when we were kids lol that
guy I like dude you know what song
ripped wow this one that wasn't even an
effect that was some guy going up be up
yeah that song ripped dude Wow
damn dude genuine for sure [__] only
for only five guys in that said and no
women genuine absolutely guaranteed only
[__] five guys and no women in his
whole life no doubt dude I wanna get
freaky BAE BAE thinking about one of the
four guys that he [__] and that's it
you know yeah yup yeah yup yup yup yup
one of the comments how many females got
pregnant from this song lol oh somebody
writes who else feels sexy AF when this
comes on and this comment is by Zhao and
cozy bed
hick hat this guy wrote I literally
searched up song that sounds like
burping and got exactly what I wanted I
mean wow
dude amazing I mean the way it's [__]
spelled pick yours of genuine ah [__] I
guess we can do uh do we have a no oh
dude really
that's hilarious one fire just said we
were trying to find [__] what they
called miss connections or that was
wrong I'm from Canada because I was just
in Canada and there aren't any weird
ones because Canada is perfect
this is four in Vancouver though this is
one of them just one just one okay this
is from Vancouver girl in sauna at
Grandview pool
oh we sat next to each other in the
sauna at Grandview pool today you had
butterfly tattoo and me with beard
wanted to say hi but I was really shy do
not contact me unsolicited services or
offers huh eh dude that's hilarious you
had a butterfly tattoo and I he had a
beard as a Canadian Wow
and then what else that's so funny girl
in sauna at Grand View hit him up dude
for some man that's so funny that that's
so of course that Canada didn't have
some [__] bad ones because they're
Canadian and they're and they all are
just like loving each other in families
and nobody needs to [__] jerk off in
a car that it there's this one another
one I'll read this is the reply there's
a reply from the sauna in Granberry pool
oh god Ari girl in sauna ha ha too funny
take a course on B
less shy second ad and giving him help
ran a person giving him how also he said
do not contact him with unsolicited
services or offers so that's [__]
[__] that you did that but so no I
spilled first spill ever on the
congratulations and it didn't [__]
hit me because I have the reflexes of a
[__] Mongoose dude but that's how
that's what Ace Ventura said in the
[__] what do you call it nah bro
we're gonna wrap up dude it is how it is
do I look as head to my [__] shoes I
just say my [__] shirt off and just
clean it that was it we spilled but
we've been spilled at the end dude cuz
that's what's up
well you get to see a real live spill
that's pretty [__] hot we're done
anyway do it it's been over an hour and
I'm just chilling and I gotta go clean
this [__] up download the cash app
for free on the App Store or Google Play
market and then you could download the
Chris D'Elia app support the show by
buying merchants tour Chris D'Elia calm
and the restock is continuous so keep a
look out and get gift cards too as well
if you're know somebody was a fan and
then tweet me and subscribe and rate and
review this show really helps and then
video episodes go up a day after the
audio and that's about it man you guys
thanks for everything I got a show in
Hoover Alabama Memphis Tennessee
Chattanooga Tennessee Knoxville
Tennessee I got all these shows coming
up so go to crystal Viacom for this [__]
and that's what's up alright you guys
thanks for listening I'm gonna go clean
this film bye bye
[Music]